on this friday night
canada's dangerous spike in covet 19
cases
hundreds more families are grieving the
loss of someone they love
ontario obliterates another record
alberta doctors take matters into their
own hands
and containing a crisis in
saskatchewan's jails
it's worse when you know that their
life's in danger
mission inoculation the top general
tasked with canada's vaccine rollout a
free-for-all with
zero fact-checking your constitutional
right to free speech
the user's flocking to new social media
platforms
where they can say anything and get away
with it
and homeward bound calgary bids goodbye
to a pair of pandas
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
chris galas good evening and thanks for
joining us we begin tonight with the
alarming toll kovid 19
is taking across the country today
ontario recorded its highest daily
number of new cases
more than 1800 20 more people have died
manitoba which has the most active cases
in the country
reported another 344 cases
and 14 new deaths that province now has
a record 322 people in hospital
45 patients are in intensive care and
today
bc broke its daily record with 911
new cases the province also added 11
more deaths
and today new brunswick recorded 12 new
infections as it becomes the latest
province
to withdraw from the atlantic travel
bubble
we're in some of the toughest days of
this pandemic
winter is coming we're going to have to
hold on tight
intensive care units at hospitals across
the country
are filling up and some are already
operating over capacity
that's the case in alberta which has
seen record-setting case numbers this
week
today a group of doctors there announced
the formation of its own
covid19 pandemic committee they say
increasing cases and what they call a
decrease in public trust
in the alberta government pushed them to
act
saskatchewan's health authority says icu
capacity is nearing a hundred percent
after a five-fold increase in covet 19
cases over the past month
the province recorded 329 new cases
today
and four more deaths and it's not just
hospitals that are feeling the strain
there is growing concern among
prison staff and inmates after a spike
in cases
at a saskatoon correctional facility
ryan kessler reports
this here is my birthday and his
birthday jennifer lownsberry is
desperate to know whether or not her son
alex has covid19
he's in the saskatoon correctional
center i'm sitting back here and i'm
just waiting for them to call me and say
that
my son has got covet and that's what i'm
thinking
as her son awaits sentencing for auto
theft covet 19 has torn through
saskatoon's jail in a matter of days
several dozen new cases
nearly all of them inmates testing is
ongoing and new prisoners will be sent
to jails in regina and prince albert
to try to reduce further spread it's
hard enough when your son
when you don't have your son when they
do something but it's worse when you
know that their life's
in danger the john howard society wants
more room
for inmate distancing which means
reducing jail populations
prosecutors agreed to release some
people awaiting trial this spring
but numbers crept up over the summer and
despite calls for
prisoners to get masks they only became
mandatory
thursday while i'm happy that they're
now being provided masks
it seems as though it may be a bit too
little too late
the jail outbreak is a symptom of
widespread community transmission in
saskatchewan
the top sources places like casinos
bingo halls and
rinks rather than close them the
saskatchewan government reduced their
capacity
the premier shooting down a complete or
circuit breaker lockdown saying most
businesses are following the rules
so it would be terribly unfair and it
would have a huge negative impact
to close down all those businesses and
put thousands of saskatchewan people out
of work
with health officials calling current
case numbers unsustainable and
intensive care units at capacity the
saskatchewan union of nurses considers
the province's moves
half measures registered nurses are
feeling
like no one's listening all the way from
the leadership of the province to the
public
a huge challenge has been contact
tracing a single positive case can
create
hours of work as a result provincial and
federal government workers along with
employees from statistics canada
are being called in to help back up
health care workers
chris all right ryan kessler in
saskatoon
thank you manitoba's chief nursing
officer says the province's
intensive care units are now operating
at well over normal capacity
and as the system becomes overwhelmed
today the manitoba government is
announcing a wage top up for some
health care workers the 35 million
caregiver wage support program
will provide an extra five dollars an
hour to about twenty thousand front line
workers
for two months the extra money will go
to those working in group homes homeless
shelters and personal care and
retirement
homes only those making under 25 dollars
an hour
can apply the federal government has
tapped a top
general in the armed forces to help get
millions of canadians inoculated for
covid19 and as our chief political
correspondent david aiken tells us there
will be some big
challenges distributing the vaccine as
quickly as possible
david well chris ottawa has
tapped major general danny forte to lead
the government's
logistics when it comes to a countrywide
rollout of a covid19 vaccine
a former army commander forte is a
well-respected top
army commander with service in iraq and
afghanistan
most recently he helped out last spring
when army personnel were dispatched to
help look after residents
in some long-term care facilities in
ontario and quebec
the canadian armed forces will assist on
planning including to meet challenges
like
cold storage requirements data sharing
and reaching indigenous and rural
communities
for tam will lead a squad of 27 armed
forces personnel including
pharmacists engineers and information
technology experts and all of them
will be embedded for the foreseeable
future with the public
health agency of canada ontario has also
tapped a top
general or at least a former top general
rick hillier
who will lead that province's vaccine
distribution efforts
hilliar thinks it was a smart move by
ottawa to bring in forte
he is the most incredible leader that i
can imagine
i could not praise him enough i am so
absolutely delighted that he is
commanding the task force
for the armed forces and the federal
government have a daunting task ahead
they must arrange for the delivery of 6
million doses of vaccines
that will require extraordinary handling
one vaccine candidate the one made by
pfizer
must be stored in special freezers at
minus
70 degrees celsius that requirement
alone makes this vaccine distribution
a job for the military but so does its
size
and scope this will be the biggest
immunization
in the history of the country we must
reach everyone who wants a vaccine
no matter where they live still most
vaccines will be distributed through
provincial channels and today many
premiers were impatient to get
more details about when where
and how they'll get the vaccines to
distribute to their citizens
chris david aiken in ottawa thanks david
with covid 19 cases surging in virtually
every part of the country a new
ipsis poll shows canadians are
overwhelmingly supportive of government
restrictions to curb the spread of the
virus
the poll done exclusively for global
news shows 72 percent of people agree
with a four-week shutdown of all
non-essential businesses
equally as many support an extended
school closure
over the holidays when it comes to
wearing a face mask
88 percent agree with wearing them in
public that's
up two points since october and as the
holidays approach most canadians say
they'll stay put
just 15 percent are planning to travel
outside the country this winter
well looks like a lot of people are
leaning on retail therapy to get them
through the
pandemic the black friday bonanza is on
both online and at traditional brick and
mortar stores
jennifer johnson shows us the bargain
hunters who braved the crowds
and kovit 19 looking for a deal
wearing masks in most cases and
physically distancing
millions of americans kicked off their
holiday shopping season by waiting in
long lines
outside big retail stores but there
wasn't nearly the pandemonium this black
friday than in pre-pandemic years
i tried to wear my mask as much as
possible to you know
limit the risk of getting coveted in
case there was someone who had it
but i felt for the most part pretty safe
the line is moving pretty quick and we
came a little bit early
so we've only been standing in line for
about five minutes
and we're already almost in this year
the navigating is going to happen more
virtually than in person
one of the things we're seeing this
season is due to the pandemic
a lot of people are shifting their
shopping online for the first time
online sales are expected to shoot up as
much as 30 percent
while stores are enforcing capacity
limits and taking other precautions
many shoppers feel safer finding deals
at home for black friday i could sit in
front of my machine
and hit five stores at the same time
millions who lost their jobs or had
hours cut back
will spend less this year christmas is
going to be a heck of a lot smaller
you know financially still the national
retail federation has a jolly forecast
predicting an increase in sales between
3.6 and 5.2 percent
companies aren't taking extra steps like
free shipping or curbside pickup to
attract buyers
those who don't offer that will be at a
disadvantage as we go into this holiday
week
experts say with cyber monday just
around the corner consumers are advised
to shop early
with online sales expected to break
records
and delays in shipping after staff
cutbacks at the u.s postal service
with the pandemic everything is
different right we're just trying to
navigate our way through it
jennifer johnson global news washington
global news has learned senator marie
sinclair is planning to leave the upper
chamber at the end of january the
manitoba senator says he wants to spend
more time focusing on writing a memoir
and working as a mentor on issues
involving indigenous law in canada
the 69 year old was the first indigenous
judge in manitoba
and the former chief of the truth and
reconciliation commission
in a statement announcing his pending
departure sinclair says quote
i leave the senate feeling happy with
how things are progressing
and knowing that reconciliation will
take a long time
i will continue to work on this for the
rest of my life
sinclair was entitled to remain as a
senator until
2026 wellness checks
under scrutiny coming up new strategies
to help people
in mental distress that don't involve
police
canadian police departments respond to
tens of thousands of mental health calls
every year many of those are wellness
checks
but in several high profile cases
they've escalated into violence and even
death
global's fara nasser has been exploring
different strategies for wellness checks
that don't involve police a call comes
in for someone in mental health distress
and it's not police who respond in
eugene oregon
but a civilian health team pretty much
everybody we see
is for one reason or another in a state
of crisis this is the future mental
health advocates want to see
a change in how we view wellness checks
not as an
incident police need to respond to but
as a medical call
we're the wrong entity in the first
place there's a space in there for
somebody other than a uniform we met
with the peel regional police chief
and the canadian mental health
association they've partnered to deliver
a mobile crisis response team
known as msert i think there's a
willingness actually
to to hand over that responsibility to
health care
which you don't always see a big problem
resources in a region with 1.4 million
people
there are only two mobile teams
in toronto the gerstein center's
non-police mobile crisis teams have been
responding to those in need for decades
we try to meet people where they're at
we try to be you know
not judgmental we try to acknowledge how
difficult
situation can be for somebody and many
more services like the gerstein centers
are needed
to take the time to do it right that's
where asante haughton and rachel
bromberg come in
there is a stigma there is an
association that people have in their
minds between mental health crisis calls
and violence
but in the real world it just doesn't
exist
they co-founded the reach-out response
network which advocates for a non-police
mental health emergency service
available 24
7. we're talking about peer workers
we're talking about mental health nurses
we're talking about clinicians and these
are the folks that we really want to be
a part of our
mental health crisis response teams back
in oregon out of the tens of thousands
of calls last year
the mental health teams only needed
police back up less than one percent of
the time
saving lives and millions of dollars
nasser global news toronto
and farah delves even deeper into
wellness checks tomorrow night at seven
on the new reality right here on global
still ahead as big tech cracks down on
misinformation
some users shift to alt-right spaces
you've heard about mud slinging in
politics but how about
throwing pig guts and punches lawmakers
in taiwan threw both in a bitter dispute
over u.s pork
imports the main opposition party is
angry over the government's decision to
allow meat containing the controversial
additive
ractopamine an agent that promotes
leanness
the ruling party condemned the behavior
calling it a waste of
food well donald trump has used twitter
to great effect
stoking in many ways fear and division
in the united states
but new social media platforms are
emerging that seem to take it to a whole
new level
jackson proskow takes a look at how
conservatives are flocking to new
sites like parlor where many falsehoods
and
outright lies go unchallenged
take a scroll through donald trump's
twitter feed and you'll see every false
claim about election fraud
flagged with a warning from the social
media giant we focus
on addressing attempts to undermine
civic integrity
providing informative context what
twitter sees as fact checking has led
some to cry
censorship who the hell elected you
the feud has given rise to alternative
social media platforms
like parlor co-founded by republican
mega donor rebecca mercer
protects your constitutional right to
free speech promising no rules no
moderators and no
fact checking parlor has rocketed to the
top of app store charts in recent weeks
becoming a breeding ground for
conspiracy theories like false claims
about pandemic concentration camps in
canada
twitter has always been viewed by
conservatives as an outside force that
has
too much control over what they do and
what they say which is ironic because
it's actually been a platform that
conservatives including donald trump
have done really well on
trump's election defeat has started a
movement away from platforms and media
outlets seen as insufficiently loyal
it's not just twitter and facebook fox
news
once a reliable bastion is under fire
from right-wing conservatives
for fact checking the president's claims
of election fraud
that our precious democracy was not
tampered with
obscure tv networks newsmax and one
america news have seen their ratings
soar
by promoting conspiracy theories that
favor trump
experts warn these alternative platforms
risk insulating their audience from
reality
offering little space for competing
views potentially boosting extremism
this idea that there is no room for
disagreement
is a new phenomenon of the trump era
there's also a limited audience for
platforms that only cater to one
narrow point of view it took nearly a
decade
for them to get to this magnitude
and a niche platform
isn't really going to be able to rival
that in a time of intense political
polarization
that likely won't stop the push to build
more spaces where people can simply play
by their own rules
jackson proskow global news washington
a prominent iranian nuclear scientist
has been
killed in what's being described as a
targeted attack
mohsen fakhrizzada was shot and killed
in an ambush by gunman while traveling
in his car
on the outskirts of tehran according to
iranian state media
western intelligence agencies believe
fakrizada was behind a covert
iranian nuclear weapons program the
increased tension could also
complicate u.s president-elect joe
biden's efforts to return the u.s
to a pact aimed at ensuring iran does
not have enough highly enriched uranium
to make a nuclear weapon no one has
claimed responsibility for the attack
but
iran is pointing the finger at israel
so-called zombie minks are popping out
from
graves in denmark weeks after a policy
saw millions of them slaughtered
hundreds of carcasses buried under
shallow soil
are pushed to the surface by gases
forming during decomposition
the animals were called after they were
found to be carrying a mutated strain of
the covid19 virus
now the government wants to dig up the
dead mink
and burn them what's black and white
and out of bamboo next the pandas
departing calgary zoo
check out this rare discovery in
thailand researchers found the massive
12 meter long skeleton
of what they believe is a brutus whale
it's thought to be between three and
five
thousand years old the whales are still
found in thailand's waters where they
are
considered a protected species another
vulnerable species is the panda and for
years zoo goers in calgary
have had the rare chance to see them up
close but
the panda's tenure is coming to an end
three years
earlier than expected the pair eats a
lot of bamboo
which is difficult to find these days so
as mike armstrong shows us
this chapter of panda diplomacy is
ending
it was a good buy the calgary zoo didn't
want to happen
this early it just didn't have a choice
air shun
and damao were mowing through about 80
kilograms of bamboo a day
the difficult decision was made in may
to send them back to china
because its supply chain had broken down
due to covet 19.
it was having trouble finding enough
bamboo calgary zoo's
standard of animal care doesn't work
well with unknown
well there wasn't much fanfare for the
departure the zoo posted a few pictures
of the pandas in crates
and being loaded onto a cargo plane for
the trip back
now it was a very different scene in
2013 when the pair
arrived on canadian soil the welcoming
committee on that day
included the prime minister well that
was quite a moment
it's not every day in your life you get
the sign for pandas
the pair spent five years at the toronto
zoo before
going to calgary they weren't quite a
gift to canada more of an
honor bestowed by china that also came
with a price tag
the zoos paid about a million dollars a
year to the chinese government's
giant panda conservation fund but the
loaning out of pandas
is fairly rare they're only in about 20
zoos around the world
used as a sort of cuddly instrument of
chinese diplomacy
they're popular people love them in many
parts of the world
china has used panda as an expression
of friendship now friendship sometimes
has
peaks and valleys the deal that landed
air shown into mao in canada was made
when relations between the countries
were considerably more amicable
well today with tensions high pandas may
be less
trivial than they seem i think it's so
important
when diplomacy isn't working well that
we maintain contacts with china at the
people-to-people level
a big part of the loaning out program is
conservation the money from canada has
helped
protect the animals in china there are
fewer than 2 000 in the wild today
which may seem small but it's actually
up close to 20 percent
over the last decade mike armstrong
global news
and that is global national for this
friday night i'm chris galas tonight's
your canada
is the coast of northern bay
newfoundland and labrador
thanks very much for watching hope you
have a great evening and a great weekend